what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
spider-man of course and if you have
been keeping up with all of the recent
events of spider-man knowing home and
the actors that have come along with
spider-man no way home also spoiler
alert if you haven't seen spider-man no
way home yet we're about to talk about
spoilers andrew garfield toby mcguire
tom holland they're all kind of starting
to speak up about the film and about all
of the rumors and about all the lies
that they kind of had to tell to not
spoil that they were in the movie now
right away people kind of say lies i
don't really consider them lies because
of course they're not going to come out
and say yes i am returning as spider-man
in this film so is toby and you're going
to be seeing the three of us swinging
together on screen for the first time
ever they're not going to be able to say
that obviously so they're not really
lies they're kind of just necessary fibs
that they had to tell to avoid the
spoilers and today andrew garfield has
opened up and talked about his werewolf
story and talked about why he chose that
story and talked about how hard it was
and stressful it was for him to have to
lie to everybody so if you want to know
what andrew garfield was thinking during
this whole time where he was telling
people that he's not in the movie that
he's not the werewolf that the leaked
photos were photoshopped this is the
video for you and of course if you just
love marvel and want to stay up to date
be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos so going
into this i think everybody has probably
seen the i'm not the werewolf video and
the it's a photoshop video but if you
haven't here's it real quick i heard
about it
and i did see it
and it's a photoshop
we say no
i'm trying to manage expectations you
say no oh you say no
you want to recommend that you chill
like like listen you know that game i
think it's kind of similar where it's
like you're convincing everyone that
you're not in the mafia right
like i feel like i'm in a gay werewolf
or mafia where i'm like i'm not the
werewolf so after consistently denying
that he would be returning as his
spider-man from the amazing spider-man
universe of course andrew garfield did
return and was in spider-man knowing
home with toby maguire and quite
honestly he was one of the best parts of
the movie his character was really
really strong and you could tell that he
had been dealing with a lot since the
loss of gwen and here he talks about
what it was like to keep this whole
thing a secret and i have to say he
really did think this out and i agree
with him on why he had to really keep
everything a secret because he had the
fans in mind but let's talk about what
he recently said in an interview with
the rap while reminiscing on having to
keep the whole thing a secret and having
to lie to the public about his role in
the movie he said that it was stressful
he said it was stressful i'm not gonna
lie it was rather stressful but also
weirdly enjoyable now for those of you
who haven't played the game werewolf
i'll have to explain it so you can
understand this part also it's kind of
like the game mafia if you've ever
played that game basically there's a
group of people and a few of them are
chosen to be a werewolf who nobody else
knows about they're in disguise and the
whole goal of the game is for everybody
to guess who the werewolf is so andrew
says it was like this massive game of
werewolf that i was playing with
journalists and with people guessing and
it was very fun and to be honest it does
look like he had a lot of fun when he
was saying i'm not the werewolf i'm
trying to manage expectations here like
they might be doing something
but
then ain't none like
i ain't got a call he did laugh a lot in
all of these interviews and it looked
like he truly was enjoying it but he
goes on to say there were moments where
i was like gosh i hate lying i don't
like to lie and i'm not a good liar but
i kept framing it as a game and i kept
imagining myself purely as a fan of that
character which is not hard to do i
placed myself in that position of well
what would i want to know would i want
to be toyed with what i want to be lied
to would i want to be kept on my toes
guessing would i want to discover it
when i went to the theater would i want
to be guessing guessing guessing and i'm
glad that he put so much thought into
what the fans would want now i also
don't believe that he really could say
that he would be in the film but i think
he went about this the right way and he
does say more but let's talk about this
real quick because he could have simply
said things like no comment i can't
answer that or simply just no i'm not in
the film sorry and sony could have come
out and said look guys we're trying to
manage your expectations for real
they're not in the film there are indeed
a lot of different ways that they could
have gone about doing everything but i
actually like how andrew garfield went
about his way because he did deny
everything but he did it in a way that
we didn't believe him and he did that on
purpose right he was toying with us he
wanted to keep us guessing so he
intentionally told us no but he did it
in a way that made us kind of not
believe him he toyed with us and he did
keep us guessing and it truthfully was a
lot of fun and it did keep us guessing
when he was on the jimmy fallon show and
he was like i don't know what photo
you're talking about show me the photo i
can tell you and then without seeing the
photo he goes oh i know the photo it's
photoshopped and just even the whole bit
with jimmy fallon where he goes well i
say no it's not photoshopped it's just a
great bit and everybody loved it and of
course he said no but everybody was like
okay now this really means yes so he did
it in a great way but he goes on to say
that if he were in the shoes of a
spider-man fan which he says isn't hard
to do because he is a spider-man fan he
said i would want the actor to do an
incredibly good job at convincing me he
wasn't in it and then i would want to
lose my mind in the theater when my
instinct was proven right that's what i
would want and he says a little bit more
but truthfully talking about this part
right here i think this is what we all
wanted yes we had speculated about the
three spider-man forever i talked about
it for more than a year before the movie
even came down and i would say yes my
sources told me that they're in it but
since sony did not confirm it and since
none of the actors confirmed it there
was always this little sliver of doubt
in the back of all of our heads that
made us go well what if they're not in
the movie and what that little sliver of
doubt did is make everything more
exciting because we didn't know 100
going into the theater whether or not
they would be in it and then when we
finally saw them on screen it was the
best moment ever so i agree with andrew
garfield here and i appreciate what he
did but here's what he has to say final
words like anyone who's played the game
werewolf knows if you are the werewolf
your heart kind of sinks because you
know you have a stressful couple of
hours ahead of you you're gonna have to
lie to your friends faces and try to
convince them that you are not the bad
guy in the game but it was thrilling
actually and of course it was thrilling
because at the end of the day andrew
garfield got to return as spider-man a
character that he is a true fan of and
he did not ruin the surprise for anybody
he played it very very well in a way
that a lot of people would post online
or message me or tweet out or comment in
the youtube section saying like andrew
said he wasn't in it and i believe him i
don't think he's in it and for those
people who thought that when they saw
him on screen i'm sure it was just the
best moment ever and at the same time
we're all going you sly little dog
andrew garfield you really had some of
us fooled and i can just imagine andrew
talking to some of his friends
his actual friends telling them like
yeah no i'm i'm not in it man and then
he's getting text messages and phone
calls after going you are in it oh my
gosh you really got me fooled and i
can't imagine that it was an actual
pretty good time for andrew garfield and
possibly toby as well we didn't really
get a lot of interviews with toby but we
did get a lot with andrew hopefully now
that the movie is out and once they
start actually advertising the three
spider-man and trailers and such we'll
get to hear from toby mcguire eventually
because i really want to know his
thoughts on what it was like to return
and work with andrew garfield and tom
holland in the meantime let me know in
the comments down below did you believe
andrew garfield when he said he wasn't
going to be in the movie or did you
think that it was all an act and you
knew that he was going to be in it and
tell the truth don't lie let us know
your true thoughts in the comments down
below for live updates you can always
follow me on instagram and twitter don't
forget to like this video and subscribe
to stay up to date on all things mcu and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof